الشيء الاخر سياده الرئيس انا اعتقد ان
تركيا
ستشعر ستنزعج من هذا الاعلان قال تنزعجنا
على ابو تركيا بقد ابو ايران
[موسيقى]
في الانس البعيد ها هو صدام يدخل على
العرب وشاهدوا حفاوه لاستقبال والهيبات
وفي اللمس القريب هو رئيس الحكومه حيدر
العبادي يقترب من اوباما ولكن لا حياه لمن
تناديه وكما يقولها المصريون
اعمل نفسك ميت اعمل نفسك ميت العراق
الجريح ينزف على الدوام الامددتم الينا
ايديكم ايها العرب البلد الذي كان وجهه
للعرب اصبح العرب يديرون وجوههم عنه
متناسين فضله بلاد الرافدين تحولت الى
ساحه لتصفيه الحسابات بين القوى الاقليميه
والدوليه المتصارعه لا احد منهم ينظر الى
رغبه العراقيين في تحيد بلادهم عن هذه
الصراعات لعلم لا يحترم سياده الدوله وضح
العراق كفريسه اجتمعت عليها الذئاب فماذا
عن العراق في عهد صدام وماذا عنه اليوم
وماذا عن جيش صدام وماذا عن جيش العراق
اليوم وماذا عن الاقتصاد في عهد صدام
وماذا عنه اليوم هذا ما سنجيب عنه خلال
دقائق هذا الفيديو
الحنين للماضي قال الحسن الثاني ملك
المغرب الراحل عندما كان يتحدث صد القمه
كنا نصمت كان على رؤوسنا الطير الملك
الحسن الحسن ملك المغرب الله يرحمه يعني
فاخذ يتحدث لي عن الرئيس صدام والله
وبالله الاخ صدام اذا حضر مؤتمرات القمه
او شيء من القبيل يقول لي وكان عروسنا
الطير امتلك الرئيس صدام اراده صلبه لا
تقبل الخضوع واستعدادا للمواجهه ايضا
ولديه كم هائل من العناد وعدم الخنوع ولعل
هذا كان سببا كافيا للاطاحه به لكن الان
وبعد رحيله هل هناك قيمه لاستحضار اسم
الرئيس القائد بعد ان اصبح عرفات داخل
قبره في مسقط راسه بالعوج وهناك سؤال اهم
ما الذي يجعل الناس اصلا يستحضرون صدام
حسين في مثل هذه المواقف الم يكن
ديكتاتورا كما يقول عنه البعض العراق يدخل
بقوته لغزو الجاره الكويتيه والعراقيون
يتحدثون الان من اراضي الكويت هاتف الرئيس
صدام حسين يرن انه الرئيس التونسي السابق
زين العابدين بن علي على العراق ان ينسحب
فورا بان العراق بوابتنا الشرقيه التي
نتكئ عليها واذا النهار العراق لا سمح
الله فلا يدومنا احد ان تجهزنا للتطبيع مع
اسرائيل وهو ما حدث بالفعل انهار العراق
ورخص الدام ووصل العرب حاليا لمرحله
التطبيع عبر صفقه القرن المزعوم صدام يهدد
اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
وهنا صواريخ صدام تمطر تل ابيب بالامس
كذبوا وسخروا ان صواريخ صدام لم تمس
اسرائيل وانها مجرد اضحوكه ياتي الرد من
اسرائيل معلنه خسائرها من قصف العراق وهنا
المصدر الاسرائيلي يتحدث
[موسيقى]
يجدي البكاء على الماضي ولن تنفع الاهات
بعد اليوم تدور بنا عجله الاحداث قليلا
فتحت بنا الرحاله في التاسع من عبر العام
2003 الاحتلال الامريكي يجوب العاصمه
بغداد ليانهل رجل يدعى كاظم حسن الجبوري
بالمطرقه على قاعده تمثال الرئيس العراقي
الراحل صدام حسين وسط بغداد قبل ان تسقطه
القوات الامريكيه وبعد اكثر من 13 عاما
على تلك الحادثه اعلن الجبوري ندمه على
تحطيم التمثال واتمنى ان يعود صدام بعد كل
ما شهده العراق خلال تلك المده من قتل
وتدمير وليس ندما على صدام بل حسره على
الدوله التي بناها صدام وانهاها الاحتلال
الامريكي الى غير الرجعه هذا الجبوري يمثل
الغالبيه العظمى من الشعب العراقي بجميع
الطوائفه واحزابه وهذا ليس كلاما يطلق في
الهواء بل هو رد بعد صدور تقرير لجنه
التحقيق البريطانيه الذي انتقد بشده
مشاركه لندن بقياده توني بلير في غزو
العراق الى جانب الولايات المتحده لمصرح
الجابوري بانه يتمنى عوده صدام رغم ان نحو
عشره من اقربائه اعظموا اثناء حكمه وذلك
حسب رويترز فكيف اصبح العراق كابوسا لا
يحتمل بعد ان كان العراقيون يحلمون لسنوات
بالزوال القبضه الحديديه لحكم صدام حسين
الذي اجبر البعض على الهرب الى المنافي
لكن اليوم بعد عقدين من الاحتلال الامريكي
اصبح العراق هو المنفى الحقيقي لابنائه
بعد ان قتل الامريكانو اكثر من مليون
عراقي وشردوا اكثر مما قتلوه فرج الاحتلال
لكن الازمات لم تخرج فتردت الاوضاع
السياسيه والاقتصاديه حتى الحياه
الاجتماعيه من ناحيه المعيشه اصبحت صعبه
جدا
ليمزي الحزن هاجس العراقيين الذي يشربونه
ولا يفارقهم حتى في افراحهم من القوه
المرعبه الى الهواء نعم لقد مرت عشرون سنه
على الغزو الامريكي للعراق ولا يزال هذا
البلد الغني بالنفط يتخبط في مشاكل سياسيه
واقتصاديه خانقه فشلت الحكومات المتعاقبه
التي تناوبت على السلطه منذ سقوط نظام
صدام حسين في 2003 ببناء اقتصاد قوي رغم
الثروات الطبيعيه الهائله التي تمتلكها
بغداد وفشلت ايضا في محاربه الفساد فمن
يتذكر ذلك الوزير الفاسد الذي اخذ من
خزينه الدوله ما ليس له فاجبره صدام على
اعاده ما اخذ او ان يبيع احدى كليتيه
ليعيد المال المنهوب الحساب للعامل ابسط
من الحساب على المدير العام لنفس الخطا
في النوايا السيئه وحساب الوزير
اشد من الحساب اللي يقع على المدير العام
او على الملاحظ وبعد مرور 20 عاما على
الغزو الامريكي تحول العراق الى قنبله
موقوته يمكن ان تنفجر في اي لحظه اذ ان
الدوله غائبه والطوائف والعصابات تتحكم في
الوضع اما نسبه الفقر فقد ارتفعت رغم ان
العراق يحتل المرتبه الخامسه عالميا في
قائمه الدول الغنيه بالنفط اما القوه
العسكريه فحدث ولا حرج بعد ان خاض الجيش
العراقي حربا طويله مع ايران استمرت 8
سنوات وتحول الى قوه عسكريه اقليميه جعلت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تخطط لتدميره
حتى تمنعه من القيام بدور محوري في
المنطقه ليتردد الجيش العراقي بين المرتبه
الرابعه والخامسه كاقوى جيش في العالم بعد
امريكا وروسيا والصين ويصل عدد الى مليون
واربعمائه الف جندي ليعود اليوم ويحتل
المرتبه الخامسه والاربعين عالميا في 2023
فعن اي انحدار نتحدث نعم كان الجيش
العراقي مصدر فخر لكل عربي لانه كان يقارن
باعظم القوى العسكريه في العالم بل وكان
يشكل تهديدا لها لكن قوات الاحتلال حلت
الجيش العراقي لينقلب السحر على الساحر
واصطدمت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بضعف
قوه الجيش العراقي بعد ذلك حتى انه لم
يستطع مقاومه تنظيم الغربان السود ونقصد
داعش الذي يبلغ قوامه جنوده على اقصى
التقديرات ثلاثين الف مقاتل ليعلم الجيش
العراقي اليوم ان التاريخ وحده لا يكفي
الهيبه العراقيه هيبه القائد العراقي مضى
عليها اكثر من عقدين من الزمن والوقت لا
ياتي الا بالاسوء عام 2015 الرئيس
الامريكي بارك اوباما يخطف الاضواء
بتجاهله رئيس الوزراء العراقي حيدر
العبادي خلال مشاركه في مؤتمر قمه مجموعه
السبع ولكن الكرامه ليس لها قطع غيار
عبادي لم يسجل اي موقف كرده فعله ووضعه
يشرح وضع العراقي
والعراقيين يومها وفي الطرف الاخر تركيا
تهاجم من جهه وترد ايران من جهه اخرى
وجميعهم يترقصون في الاجواء العراقيه
ويقصفون العراقيين فضلا عن التوغلات
البريه والضحيه دائما هم ابناء العراق
فماذا لو كان صدام هو من يحكم اليوم هل
كان ليجرا احد على خرق سياده العراقيه
العراقيون يعلمون الاجابه جيدا لكن انقره
وطهران لا تتوقفان وبناء السدود يتواصل
بشكل مخيف ويمتصون مياه نهري دجله والفرات
لتتسع رقعه الجفاف والتصحر على الاراضي
العراقيه والرافدين لم يعودا يرفدان
العراق بالماء والعراقيون يصرخون اعيدوا
لنا صدام وستعود مياهنا وسيادتنا فلتنظر
الى الامام يا ابناء صدام فلا مجال للعوده
الى الوراء عندما استلم صدام حسين نظام
الحكم ما بين عامي
[موسيقى]
1979,03 كانت الميزانيه ما بين 20 21 الى
32 مليار دولار نذهب 80% الى التصنيع
العسكري بينما بلغت ميزانيه العراق في
العام 2003 حوالي 14 مليار دولار لترتفع
الى 18 مليار دولار في العام التالي ولكن
اليوم الفساد ينخر الجسد العراقي واكبر
دليل هي سرقه القرن العراقيه والتي قدرت
بثلاثمائه وست مليار دولار فلوزع هذا
المبلغ على العراقيين لا تزوج الشعب
العراقي مثنى وثلاثه ورباع ولا ود على
العراقيون الفقر الى غير رجعه العراق يئن
وحيدا والشرق والغرب يراقبون بلدا حكمه
صدام واوصله لمصافي اقوى دول العالم وحكمه
اخرون فلم يجد العراقيون غير الفقر والجوع
بدون هيبه دوليه او سياده للبلاد والسؤال
اليوم لاشقائنا العراقيين هل تمنيتم يوما
ان يعود العراق الى الماضي بينما يسير
العالم نحو المستقبل
[موسيقى]